Hey youtubers it's Charlie and Teen Wolf is
back for the Summer.
Since a lot of you asked me to do videos for
it I'm going to be doing weekly vids.
I'm not planning on doing Q&A videos or anything
like that, but if you want me to do bonus
videos like I did for Game of Thrones let
me know.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
This episode is kind of that limbo state between
the old crew when we still had Allison and
Isaac and the new Team with Malia and Kira.
There's a bunch of new characters this season
and it's going to completely change the tone
of the show, but we had to have this episode
to bridge the gap, following up what happened
to Derek.
The theme of Season 4 overall is "Can't Go
Back", which is interesting because this week
we went on a Mexican Road Trip.
So what I'm going to do is my top 5 moments
from the episode, then my review and then
I'll talk about what's going to to be new
in Season 4 and why that's a good thing.
I'll just tease right now, if you liked Season
1, you're going to love Season 4.
So careful for spoilers from the episode in
case you haven't seen it, but here we go.
Number 5 - Wolfsbane Gas Dance Party
The reason they went to the club was because
they found werewolf hunter shell casings with
the insignia of that family, the Calaveres,
they're another hunter family just like the
Argents.
They're not really bad or good.
They're just nazi's about the Hunter's Code.
The Dance Party is just the introduction to
the 'new team', like their grand stage entrance.
I love that Malia was the one who had to tell
Kira to 'fit in', when she's the worst person
in the world at fitting in.
The two of them are still kind of outsiders
even after spending season 3 trying to help
Scott and Stiles.
There was a bit of Malia Kira 'ship teasing
here, but I don't think that's going anywhere.
I think the show is really going to push the
Malia Stiles and Kira Scott ships.
Number 4 - Teen Wolf Recapping
This episode is all about bridging the gap
between the old team and the new team, so
naturally the car ride is used to tell the
story of Seasons 1 through 3.
Even the pre-history on how Paul became the
Alpha.
Kate is one of the craziest villains the show
has had and she's supposed to be a big part
of the plot in Season 4.
She's not necessarily going to be the main
villain and I don't think she's the mysterious
Benefactor that we've been teased with in
the trailers.
But I'll talk about that in a sec.
All this recapping is just setting us up for
next week when everyone comes to the realization
that you can't come back from the horrible
things that have happened.
They can't just go back to being normal, they
have to push forward with what they have.
It's a metaphor for what happened with Derek,
the physical transformation and the show itself,
both Crystal Reed and Daniel Sharman asked
to leave the show and anytime a show loses
two major characters things get weird.
I don't think Teen Wolf is reinventing itself
in Season 4, but it is doing a soft reset,
which is why I think it's going to feel a
lot like Season 1 did.
Which I will explain after my review.
Number 3 - Lydia's Abilities Get Tested
Apparently killing people in whichever town
they're in is no big deal.
I love that nobody made a sound, no screams,
no police sirens.
This big test informs what's going to be happening
with Lydia's character this season.
She's going to be developing her powers to
the point where she can be way more CSI with
the way she derives clues.
Even though she and Stiles are reconnecting
I don't think there will be any real romance
between them, not a full on love triangle
with Malia, but I think she's going to use
Stiles as an anchor to reality.
She's probably grown more as a character since
Season 1 than anyone else on the show.
I love Holland Roden, but Season 1 Lydia was
pretty off-putting before her transformation.
That's just her hero's journey.
If you're not familiar with Joseph Campbell's
Hero with a Thousand Faces, it spells out
the archetypal Hero's journey from normal
person to hero.
A lot of fiction and television writers use
it to develop characters.
Lydia's Journey in Season 4 is going to be
learning to master the supernatural and retain
her humanity.
Becoming Master of both worlds.
The same thing is happening with the other
characters and their own situations like Scott
being the Alpha and Malia learning to be Human.
Number 2 - Derek Is Transformed into Young
Derek
The Derek we see is his younger self played
by the actor Ian Nelson who has played young
Derek in flashbacks.
There are a number of giant questions raised
by this including, what is the effect of the
Dark Moon on the Supernatural, what is the
significance of the Aztec Temple belonging
to the werejaguars and why was Derek intombed
behind a symbol of their god?
Who was the figure in Bone armor?
Because it definitely wasn't Kate.
She was busy harassing the Jeep crew while
Scott and Braeden were in the tombs.
And how is this all connected to the Benefactor
and the Deadpool List?
Since this episode was all about finding Derek,
presumably episode 2 will introduce the rest
of the new characters, the Benefactor and
the Deadpool.
The deadpool is both an awesome homage to
the comic book character Deadpool and it's
a kill list of all the supernatural creatures
living in Beacon Hills.
It's like Teen Wolf is going to be paying
homage to Death Note this season and the Benefactor
will be like the Light Yagami of the story.
So if you liked that anime, you're going to
love season 4.
and my Number 1 moment - WTF is Kate
It's pretty clear she's not just a werewolf.
Based on her taking Derek to the Aztec temple
I think we can assume she's a were jaguar.
I love the way the show deepens the mythology
every season, last year got a little crazy
with the Kitsune, the Oni, Nemeton etcetera.
Supposedly this season is supposed to be a
bit of a reprieve from the super dark direction
things went.
They're not just going to keep making it more
depressing and make us all feel awful every
week.
That's why they're weaving a lot of familiar
things like Lacrosse back into the story in
a big way.
They're headed back to Beacon Hills, so I
think that the Benefactor will be someone
using Kate to cause more chaos.
She's supposed to be a big part of the season,
but I'm pretty sure she's not the creature
with the bone armor Scott was fighting.
That person was featured in the trailer, so
it's probably going to follow them back home
and cause a bunch of trouble between Lacrosse
Games.
I wouldn't be surprised if one of the new
characters turned out to be part of a were-jaguar
family that just moved to town and Kate was
working for them.
But now it's your turn, let me know what your
favorite moment was.
And do you have a favorite ship already.
They did say there wouldn't be a ton of romance,
but we'll definitely get some funny 'ship
moments.
I'm actually most excited to see Scott develop
his pack, an Alpha needs a pack.
And there were a few spoilers about who would
be joining him but I don't want to say who
in this video just in case you don't want
to know.
If you have heard the spoilers and what to
comment about it, just use the spoiler tags
in the comments.
Overall I gave the episode a B plus, next
to Legend of Korra it's going to be one of
my favorite summer shows.
It actually shares a lot in common with the
Avatar series.
If you've never seen Last Airbender or Legend
of Korra, it revolves around this idea of
the four elements, Air, Water, Earth and Fire.
So each new season of Avatar is themed after
an element.
The opening title scene of Teen Wolf also
revolves around elements, like when we had
the Red when Scott was becoming an Alpha which
represents the Air Element, during Season
2 we had all the Water during the opening
titles.
It's just a fun observation, but maybe the
Teen Wolf people are Avatar fans.
This season all that Sand makes me think season
4 will be earth element based.
Usually the title scenes inform what the season
is going to be about.
So be sure to write your theories for this
year in the comments.
The other thing that really stood out aside
from them trying really hard to balance between
what the show was last year and what it's
going to be this year is all of the characters
relationships with each of the other characters.
The writers said this year is going to focus
much more on the human relationships as opposed
to the crazy supernatural relationships of
season 3.
That's why were going back to a ton of Lacrosse.
It's where we started in season 1 before Scott
and everyone got thrown into the supernatural
world.
The difference this time around is that everyone
is so much more mature, and because of all
the new freshman characters, Scott, Stiles
and Lydia will be like mentors to them.
Way better mentors than Derek was to Tyler
and Stiles.
Worst mentor ever.
Unless you count Paul.
So like I said, I'm going to be doing weekly
videos for Teen Wolf this season, be sure
to subscribe to get everything.
Be sure to let me know if you want me to do
bonus mythology videos and I'll start posting
those Monday Mornings.
Right now click on either one of these annotations
to learn about Avatar Legend of Korra, it's
starting this Friday and like I said it has
a lot in common with Teen Wolf thematically.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!